nathalie normandeau bonjour orange a
alors beaucoup beaucoup d'entrevues pour
vous le rayon les spots comme on dit en
mauvais français sont sur vous depuis
deux jours j'ai entendu dire ce matin
c'est dommage qu'on ne respecte pas la
présomption d'innocence ou que vous
sentez accusé de quoi précisément d'un
côté là ça fait deux ans que mon nom est
traîné dans la boue sur la place
publique
deux ans qu'il étrennait injustement par
toutes sortes d'allégations non fondées
on a remis en question mon intégrité mon
honnêteté et j'avais j'avais hâte de
passer à la commission charbonneau parce
que la commission pour moi est un forum
une tribune pour me permettre de
rétablir les faits de blanchir ma
réputation et c'est précisément ce que
j'ai fait il ya pendant six heures avec
les comme ça mais est-ce que vous ce que
vous convenez avec moi que si normal que
les québécois veulent savoir comment on
finance et les partis politiques
il ya eu de nombreux reportages issus de
la dogana enthralled enquête là-dessus
il ya des choses qui ont révolté les
gens qu'il ya des enveloppes brunes qui
se donnait donc il est normal qu'on vous
pose des questions tout à fait en vain
wii fit d'ailleurs si je suis devant
vous c'est parce que je prête à répondre
à vos caisses c'est bon on a beaucoup vu
beaucoup questionné depuis plusieurs
jours et même avant sur le fait que marc
yvan côté vous saviez qu'il était d'une
certaine école pour le financement
politique à la commission gomery a eu
d'effet avery a distribué 100 mille
dollars cash
à l'époque vous le laissez faire du
financement politique pour le parti
libéral du québec pour quoi bon tout
d'abord ans nathalie normandeau ne
laissait pas faire du financement pour
le parti libéral du québec et d'ailleurs
tout quand on parle beaucoup beaucoup
d'importance à marc yvan côté il est
l'occasion dit à la commission
charbonneau qui est un acteur parmi tant
de monsieur roy on peut et on peut
tenter de réécrire l'histoire parce
qu'en 2014 c'est facile évidemment de
dire oh mon dieu c'était incroyable quel
scandale
ce que je vous aujourd'hui c'est que
parce qu'on ne peut pas réécrire
l'histoire
bon et qu'on ne peut pas les inventer
non parce que là quand vous prends mon
vélo jusqu'au mont granit noir mais je
vous repose simplement un peu une
accusation subventions c'est madame vous
savez que monsieur côté d'un côté
faisait du financement
oui absolument qu'ils étaient impliqués
qui vous inviter des gens dont pour
participer à des activités de
financement vous savez qui était ami
avec votre chef de cabinet oui vous
saviez qui travaillait chez roche oui
saviez que roche
vous donnez vous donniez des contrats
roche je ne donnerai pas contre à roche
des subventions municipalité qui engage
et roche vous saviez ce que zac la
responsabilité de donner de l'ouvragé
aux firmes de génie sa partie au milieu
municipal ont remis ça va faire mais pas
dans vos cocktail et souper de
financement qui existe est partout mais
dans vos cocktails à vous vous avez vu
des gens de roche
oui d'autres réduire nos charges j'ai vu
des avocats des comptables des militants
de gens de plusieurs professions donc
vous comprenez qu'il y avait un système
pour financer les partis politiques
notamment le parti libéral du québec
les firmes de génie donnait de l'argent
vous le saviez oui a fait ce système de
prête-noms été révélé avec le rapport
moisan 2006 avec les enquêteurs du
recteur du directeur général d action
2009 puisque la commission révélé et
qu'on ne savait pas c'est l'emploi des
contributions des firmes de génie
versées aux partis politiques québécois
mais aussi instruit j'arrête là en 2031
québec pourrir la colline parlementaire
et déjà les prête noms c'était quelque
chose qui était connue de peu près tout
le monde attaché politique chef de
cabinet ministre
là vous êtes une ancienne ministre est
ce que vous me dites vraiment que vous
ne saviez pas que des firmes comme roche
de neige de fortes sommes à votre parti
politique en faisant signer des employés
a vraiment bien joué mais premièrement
j'ai appris la hauteur de la contrainte
son de roche je me le prendrais un comté
de bonaventure hier à la commission soit
j'ai appris ça deuxièmement quand je
faisais du financement politique
les gens par exemple utilisé des
prête-noms n'est pas moi rêver à madame
normandeau bonsoir je m'appelle monsieur
x ou y je suis un prête-nom
mais j'ai le regret de vous dire que les
prête-noms moi comme ministre
parce que j'étais minutes à partir de
2003 cette affaire-là été mis au jour à
partir du rapport moisan 2006 j'ai le
regret de vous dire monsieur roy que je
n'étais pas informé des magouilles des
stratagèmes que tu oses et les firmes de
génie derrière leurs portes closes pour
financer les partis politiques
en 2009 les élus de l'assemblée ont dit
à ces cétacés et puis la loi sur le
financement des partis politiques a été
amendée justement pour éviter ce genre
d'abus ok alors vous maintenez j'ai posé
la question à plusieurs personnes là je
vous ai devant moi ray et je trouve que
quand il ya une commission denquête
comme ça c'est le bon moyen le bon
moment des faits c'est vrai on le savait
que les firmes donnait bien on se
doutait bien que c'est qu'ils
utilisaient leurs employés pour
légaliser sur joyce avec les entreprises
donné on les voyait à chaque côté de
finances ne vous ai pas envie que
j'étais pas au courant là c'est parce
que je vous ai dit vous m'avez vous
m'avez dit moi depuis 2000 sur la
colline qui on savait il ya le rapport
moisan qui arrive en 2006 celle là cette
affaire-là et mis au jour
alors évidemment je suis une élue à
l'assemblée nationale je suis informé du
contenu du rapport moisan j'ai
l'occasion d'y derrière la commission ce
que je ne savais pas comme ministre
c'est toute la magouille qui se passait
au près dans certaines firmes de génie
j'ai donné un exemple très concret une
firme de génie qui pourraient avoir des
contrats municipaux décident de
manipuler les membres du comité de
sélection des sites de truquer un
système d'appel d'offres décide de faire
de fausse facturation et j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire hier si sauf c'est
vrai parce qu'on parle d'allégations
j'espère que les enquêtes de l'ipac
devons donner des résultats oui là vous
isoler les cas les plus graves ou des
tissus je serai papiers ont rompu on
peut vous croire sur cette portion là
moi je vous parle d'un système 5 et
québécois c'est ça qu'ils intérêt tous
les détails les gens suivent pas ça il y
avait un système de financement qui
faisait que les firmes de génie avait
dit
au plus haut niveau votre chef de
cabinet il s'enfermait dans son bureau
avec des ingénieurs de chez roche vous
étiez la responsable de ti responsables
de seulement mais c'est entre autres ce
que j'ai appris à la commission que mon
chef de cabinet recevait quand je
n'étais pas là des ingénieurs si c'est
vrai j'ai eu l'occasion de dire qu'il
aurait trahi il se pourrait qu'il ait
trahi ma confiance et j'espère qu'il ne
le voterait lino zambito vous offre du
financement guichot pour louer vert à
québec avec vos gueules vous vous
conseillez y reçoit ensuite une partie
importante de contrats boisbriand ya une
partie qui est sous enquête policière
qu'il ya des accusations criminelles
le lien entre l'argent qu'on donne ou
parti de madame normandeau
elie compteront que l'on reçoit du
ministère il est là le lien qui fatigue
qui révoltent comme je comprends je
comprends qu'il peut y avoir on a la
voix je comprends qu'ils sont devenus en
prenez aucune peur de l'autre
mentionnant c'est pas vrai ce que je
vous dis je suis imputables de toutes
les décisions que j'ai prises et je les
assume totalement ce que je vous dis
aujourd'hui c'est qui a jamais eu de
retour d'ascenseur
nathalie normandeau brillant lieu autour
de 106 nathalie là vous êtes en train de
prétendre aujourd'hui qu'une aide
financière du ministère des affaires
municipales se serait fait
conditionnellement en tout cas les gens
qui ont reçu l'aide d'une matière
municipale chez les gens qui vous
donnait puis qui vous envoyer des robots
géants qu'il faut être très très prudent
et une enquête comme vous dites là et il
n'y a pas de lien
moi je vous ai dit je voudrais qu'il ya
pas de lui un instant je répète ce que
j'ai dit à la commission
il n'y a pas de retour d'ascenseur il
n'y a pas eu de contrat en retour de
financement politique et je réitère le
fait que ce n'est pas le ministère des
affaires municipales qui octroie le
mandat à une firme de génie ou un
entrepreneur pour construire un projet
du gibier sur la mini c'est quand même
important de sa distinction parce que
moi comme une excuse shing promesse
d'être financière
j'ai pas la liste des firmes de génie
qui nous laisse le projet là c'est telle
firme de génie qui est un pic à landos
et je n'ai pas cette information là
alors toutes ces années où les partis
politiques et notamment et on a vu les
montants la commission charbonneau parti
libéral du québec en eux reçu beaucoup
de cet argent là il n'y a pas un moment
vous avez été un confortable de voir
votre
chef de cabinet faire du financement
politique intra me avec un
vice-président de chez roche et promenez
vous avez dit il ne peut pas avoir un
mur entre les décisions éclairées de
ministre il financement ci a dû si les
portes sont ouvertes mais c'est facile
de dire aujourd'hui mais avec du recul
le fait que du personnel pour les teams
de cabinet s'implique dans
l'organisation d'activités de
financement ce n'est de toute évidence
c'est une chose à proscrire
même chose du côté du des gens qui sont
impliqués dans des firmes de génie il
faut proscrire leur participation à une
quelconque activité de financement
ça c'est des choses qu'il faut éviter
c'est le sens de la commission
charbonneau
comment on peut avec les outils dont
nous disposons sont en place comment on
peut faire davantage pour faire fuir les
collisionneur et éviter effectivement ce
genre de situation se reproduise ultime
ans qu'on cherche à faire monsieur roy
c'est de permettre aux soyez d'avoir à
nouveau confiance dans leur vin doit
changer
la nuit la route de réjection financiers
par des fonds publics a donc en grande
partie les mines et met en grande partie
parce qu'on a à bcg la faune des
contributions j'avais pas envie de me
répondre c'est vrai monsieur roy que
cette pression chez les ministres
d'aller chercher de l'argent notamment
chez le ministre des affaires
municipales
il y avait quelque chose de malsain là
dedans on devait un copain copain que
toutes les firmes de génie non c'est
même là monsieur monsieur je vous arrête
là c'est c'est fou ce que vous êtes leur
copain copain que les firmes de génie -
la milesse que j'ai été là j'ai jamais
été j'ai jamais vrai quand je vois
cabinet est ce parce que faire de votre
cabinet c'est vous bruno l'artiste une
chose est elle à la constitution
il est oui absolument ils étaient là
comme son chariot et s'est expliqué -
l'ami est-ce que je tel jeter port
copain copain avec les firmes de génie
je travaillais pas pour les firmes de
génie je travaille pour les communautés
je travaillais pour les citoyens qui
venaient cogner à ma porte c'est ça le
sens on engagement politique estimé
révolte le plus monsieur roy est la
potion à question norge d'accord ce qui
me révolte
il ya beaucoup d'exemples de son pays 2
amitié de cocktail de voyage même des
billets écouter et ça c'est condamnable
je vous le dis c'est condamnant stressé
j'ai accepté quoi bein je parlais des
billets jeudi les bienfaits reprenons
les billets l'exemple des biens pour ce
délai c'est la seule fois où j'ai
accepté des billets j'ai l'occasion de
dire je n'aurais pas dû accepter c'est
bien c'est pas parce que j'ai accepté
des biens qui a eu un traitement qui a
favorisé monsieur habito
je vous le redis aujourd'hui en
conclusion un lame normandeau vous ne
dénoncez pas le système qui s'est créé
au fil des années au québec ces fonds
qu'ils avaient non non je vous pose la
question ne dénoncez vous pas comme
d'autres
ce système qui s'est créé malsain au
québec qui a fait que des liens entre
les firmes l'on parle beaucoup des
firmes de génie je peux vous parler des
firmes d'avoir ouais c'est la firme
informatique et on donnait on recevait
on donnait on recevait pour nager dans
le bocal pour avoir des contrats
gouvernementaux
c'était non dit mais c'était une
évidence qu'il fallait contribuez vous
trouvez pas sûr de malsain vous avez dit
une chose un papa blanc donné on
recevait si on recevait ses scandales
huées
non seulement c'est scandaleux mais moi
ça me révolte monsieur parce que
savez-vous quoi ça contribue à ternir
l'image d'ensemble la classe politique
au québec
aujourd'hui c'est les élus qui paie pour
ça alors que moi j'ai fait mon métier de
façon nette et les collègues qui
m'entouraient aussi ont fait leur
travail de façon honnête alors j'espère
évidemment les recommandations de la
commission vont permettre non seulement
de faire une éclairage sur toute cette
pratique mais qu'on puisse d'enfants
s'orienter vers des vers des solutions
que le voit emporté plus de comprendre
la matité vous n'avez plus envie de
faire du pays sinon sachez ce geste et
on prend vie non non pas avec ce que
j'ai vécu depuis deux ans nomme
normandeau merci avant que l'incident 12
nous envoie du studio parce que j'ai
dépassé largement d'accord merci merci
merci beaucoup